foreign
[Music]
1900 on the nose
and uh the games have become very
serious let's see who we get this done
all right let's roll the cameras we're
black against the 2050 okay this is
gonna be juicy this is gonna be juicy
and it's going to be a good test of our
opening repertoire we're facing what
appears to be the Smith more no Knight
F3 Okay so
this is a slightly odd move order it's
not particular it's not bad for white
and if you look carefully
we actually can keep this Pawn alive
with the move E5 I think a lot of people
are attempted by that move because you
see the Knight take C5 loses the knight
to queen A5 check actually the move E5
is bad here because white gets a much
improved version of the Smith Mora with
C3 then you trade on C3 and black has
this gaping weakness on D5 as a result
so what you want to do here is
essentially play whatever Sicilian you
normally play if you're a knight or
flare then you want to go D6 here if
you're a con player you want to go E6 we
are accelerated Dragon players for the
purposes of the speed run so we're gonna
go Knight C6
and Knight takes D4 G6 transposes to the
main line but our opponent is sort of
insisting on uh on on playing this in
rather Unique Style Bishop C4
is a weird move
okay Bishop C4 let's let's unpack that
move for a second because I don't fully
understand it our opponent is delaying
Knight takes D4 why is he delaying it
I'm not entirely sure so one approach
here
would be to play G6 G6 is a totally
reasonable move and after Knight takes
D4 Bishop G7 we're back in relatively
normal territory of course this is not
really a theoretical move but I think
that we can try to punish white for
being you know overly cute rather than
just playing G6 and meekly developing I
think Knight F6 is a much better
developing move it's a much more testing
move
because it directly hits the E4 pawn and
I don't think this move has a downside
yes and this of course would be the
downside except it falls into a very
well-known tactic anytime you have a
king on E1 and anytime you play the
Sicilian you have to be aware of the
possibility of a check on A5
it would be wrong to give that check
immediately because after Bishop D2 we
lose a minor piece then our Queen hangs
and our Knight hangs this is what our
opponent is relying on but a little bit
of tactical trickery enables us to apply
this concept properly we can start by
taking on E5 I hope this is not some
sort of very deep prep and in response
to Knight takes Knight very common trick
then we play Queen A5 and we're able to
pick up the Knight and the difference is
when we play Queen A5 immediately the
Knight still defends the pawn so we
can't take it with our Queen
Knight takes E5 and we have already won
the opening battle
another thing to point out Bishop takes
F7 check could could seem annoying but
remember that we could take that Bishop
with the Knight rather than taking it
with the King and allowing white to take
on E5 with a check
oh Queen takes D4 whoa our opponent I
think continuing to dig himself into a
hole this gives us a nice choice
so the two candidate moves to me are to
take the Knight and to ruin White's
kingside Pawn structure and to take the
bishop and secure the bishop pair for
ourselves I think both options are good
it's largely a matter of taste the more
positional move is Knight takes C4
because we cash in our chips and we get
a long-term Advantage the more tactical
approach trying to win the game more
quickly I think is to take the Knight
and immediately go after whites King I
think that we should play this
methodically I like cashing in our chips
and playing positionally so let's grab
that Bishop while we still have the
chance
I also don't particularly like Knight
takes F3 because we don't have the
Machinery to actually attack White's
King just yet so it's not like we can
immediately launch a mating attack after
taking on F3 here we also have the
follow-up Tempo move D5 this seems very
natural just pushing a pawn into the
center grabbing control of the center
now you might argue that a more a move
that's more in the spirit of certain
Sicilian setups is to push the pawn one
square to D6 that's a more modest move
and then you can try to feed and ghetto
the dark squared Bishop but that's a
little bit slow and I see absolutely no
reason that we shouldn't grab control of
the center you shouldn't think of this
as a sicilian anymore this is just a
position and you know Sicilian ideas
don't necessarily apply here anymore
so let's go D5
and the queen drops back to B3
and I assume our opponent is aiming at
the B7 Pawn to make it difficult for us
to develop the light squared Bishop the
move that I think a lot of you might
think of instinctually as Queen to B6
this is often how you meet a queen on B3
across many different openings but I'm
not totally sure that a queen trade is
in our favor if we play Queen B6 and our
opponent trades and we've created for
ourselves a new Target on the queen side
that white can attack and harass with
Bishop to E3 so I think the sort of not
every piece needs to be Distributing
whatever the coveted vaccine rule
applies in the sense that we don't need
to develop our Bishop immediately we're
not under no obligation to bring our
Bishop out and the fact that the bishop
remains on C8 isn't such a big deal we
can actually work on our King side first
and then maybe later on we can feed and
keto the bishop with B6 and Bishop B7 so
Queen A5 check by the way I don't see
the point of that move it just walks
into Bishop D2 I don't see what we
achieve with a check on A5
I think that we should focus on
developing our King side that's the top
priority so that our King gets out of
the center and once it does it'll be
easier to address the problem of the
light squared Bishop I'm pretty
confident that we'll be able to play B6
and then Bishop B7 or even Bishop A6 but
only after we Castle
of course white could try to open up the
center with C4
that's absolutely not scary because our
Pawn chain in the center is super super
well protected and White's development
is significantly lacking
okay so where do we put our dark Square
Bishop again I think modest development
might be the order of the day here
Bishop D6 or Bishop C5 may seem like the
more active moves first of all Bishop C5
walks into a very unpleasant check on B5
and forces us to drop our Knight back to
D7 that's awkward Bishop D6 I'm a little
bit irked by Bishop G5 and the pin
against the Knight could be slightly
annoying because later on I do want to
be able to move the queen out to C7 for
example so I think developing modestly
with Bishop E7 uh is just a little bit
more solid because we're already up upon
we have the bishop pair we don't have
the need to develop particularly
aggressively let's just complete our
development and now we can focus on the
more pressing issues so we castle of
course we're not afraid of the X-ray
against the queen because the pawn on D5
is so well protected notice also that C4
which I think is something I our
opponent might be thinking about runs
into D takes C4 counter-attacking
White's Queen on B3 and it's easy to see
that after Rook takes d8 C takes B3 Rook
takes f8 King takes f8 white recaptures
the pawn but he'll just end up a pawn
down in a miserable end game
so far our moves have been very
straightforward now we get to the final
developmental priority which is the
question of the bishop we do want to
bring it out there's really only one way
to bring it out and that is to play B6
which we can play largely without any
hesitation
C4 yes our opponent is unable to
restrain himself he does play C4
and of course we don't have to play DC
White's not really threatening to play C
takes D5 so a good alternative would be
to complete the development of the light
squared Bishop with Bishop B7 lending
even more support to the D5 Pawn so for
example if after Bishop B7 white plays
Knight C3 we could bring our Rook into
the game with Rook C8 and if you
calculate all of the captures on D5 at
the end of the day we just establish a
super powerful Bishop on D5 which takes
the place of the pawn
but let's consider D take C4 because
that's the more concrete approach I
think our opponent in response might be
preparing the move Queen to C2
so D takes C4 Queen C2 we move our Queen
away and only then probably white is
going to capture on C4
even in that position we play Bishop B7
and as a result of this trade are
uncontested light squared Bishop is on
an absolutely ideal Square so I think
both Bishop B7 and pawn takes Pawn these
moves are essentially interchangeable it
depends on whether or not you want to
allow an end game I don't see a reason
not to
so
unless this is some sort of a blunder I
think we should play TC
trying to keep it as simple and
calculation free as possible
okay
so now the question for white he can
take the queen drop the queen back to C2
of course white cannot take on C4
because the Rooks are not coordinated
yeah Queen C2 as we discussed
and in addition to Queenie which is the
obvious move we also can block the
attack on our queen with the move Knight
to D5 which I also really really like
because that Knight is super powerful it
can be supported from behind by the
bishop so yeah the queen on E8 is a
little bit cramped it is but not really
because the queen has plenty of
prospects along the E8 A4 diagonal they
can move on to C6 later for example and
build a battery uh with the bishop that
we're about to feed keto so again these
types of positions where you have a big
Advantage you will often have two or
three moves that are largely
interchangeable that are all within the
range of being pretty good moves
so which of these moves do we want to
choose I'm going to take a minute to
think about this less than a minute
actually figure of speech
okay I I like the more aggressive
approach I think we go we go Knight T5
we establish our Knight in the center
and you can see how the absence of a a
light squared Bishop really really hurts
um
really really hurt swipe because we're
positioning two of our miners on light
squares and that's why I'm never afraid
of the pressure on D5 because I know for
a fact that white simply can't add any
attackers onto the D5 square if White
had a light squared Bishop that let's
say would move on to E4 yeah then our
Knight would be incredibly unstable as
it stands our Knight is incredibly
stable and it will be just as stable if
it is replaced by the bishop so let's
continue getting our pieces into the
game actually we have I think a really
really nice move here which I wouldn't
say forces the end game but it it it it
forces white into a very unpleasant
dilemma and some of you have noticed
this move the obvious move is Rook CA
this is also what came to my mind first
and Rook see it is a good move the queen
moves away to B3 we can bring our own
Queen up to D7 or Play Bishop F6 and
continue but we could also try to force
a trade of Queens what I'm noticing is
that there's contact between pieces
that's something you always have to see
there's contact between the Knight on D5
and the bishop on F4 which means Queen
on C4 is a little bit overextended but
this is a moot point currently because
the Knight on D5 is pinned but what if
we try to unpin the Knight while also
offering a queen trade well that
wouldn't be such a bad idea would it
that's how we get the move Queen to ca
which I think is very accurate because
in the event of the queen trade we also
get our Rook onto the square that we
want it to be on anyway so we get
control of the C file if white refrains
from the trade well white has to stay on
the fourth rank otherwise he loses the
bishop
and
I don't see where the queen can go if it
goes to D4 we could also take the Knight
on C3 and suddenly we can snap the
Knight on F3 off the board and
completely ruin White's structure on
both sides of the board or we could
secure the bishop okay well that is just
absolute resignation by our opponent
that's pretty sad because I was I was
looking forward to
you know to converting the advantage now
we just get a free point
yeah not not our opponent's best day I I
have to say
so I apologize for that
yeah we really didn't do anything in
this game
to to earn the win but I'll take it
yeah that's uh bit anti-climactic and
now our opponent starts to think which
is pretty typical Rook ac1 okay well
let's let's stay disciplined and let's
finish this game off in style it's not
over yet right we're up a piece but
if you were playing you probably
wouldn't think oh the game is over
playing a 2000 let's try to convert this
in style so first thing
I wouldn't rush with Bishop takes F3
this is essentially a move that you can
play whenever you want to so I know some
of you are probably itching to take that
night off the board but I'd like to keep
our Bishop alive for the time being and
save Bishop takes F3 for a rainy day
what is our top priority again what do
we need to fix in our position right now
there's only one source of danger which
is the X-ray against our Queen and if
you look carefully it's not even really
a source of danger because the only way
to try to exploit it is Knight to D5 if
the Knight goes the other way note that
we have a fork on E2 that's a check and
we pick off The Rook if white plays
Knight to D5 we can actually take that
Knight with our Bishop that's why I want
to keep the bishop alive this hits the
White Queen on B3 that line is very easy
to calculate Rook takes C5 Bishop takes
B3 and white will lose at the very least
another minor piece so a move that I
really like here is actually Queen to C5
which I I think is not a move that is
necessarily on most people's radar but
what I really want to achieve with this
move other than connecting the Rooks and
getting the Queen off of the eighth rank
we're creating a very concrete tactical
threat I want to finish the game on the
next move who can tell me what threat
this move creates
and I've primed You by talking about
this move a little bit earlier well not
Queen G5 because there's the Knight on
F3 but yeah you're threatening to take
the Knight and after GF swing the queen
over to G5 the King has to run toward
the center and it's gonna get hunted
down by the queen from G2 and then Queen
G1 with uh an immediate Checkmate and
King hunt
and this is very hard to defend against
Rook D7 yep and our opponent walks right
into it
Bishop takes F3 and the game is over
because
uh the the dark squared Bishop is
defended but that doesn't even matter
and now the final stage of the game we
go after White's King here's another
check
but as I've talked about in earlier
speedrun games this phase of the game
where you're essentially a couple of
moves away from Checkmate you're totally
winning and you're trying to hunt the
king down is an area where some players
actually struggle particularly newer
players and one thing that often happens
is over fixation on trying to deliver
Checkmate rather than just trying to
cash in your chips and win a bunch of
materials so that's what we're gonna do
here first things first we can make a
couple of no-brainer moves to win
another pawn and force whites King uh
even further into confinement I'm of
course talking about another check on G1
followed by Queen takes F2 check that
forces the king back to D1 and there
would be nothing wrong with taking the
pawn on F3 with check okay our opponent
is just giving up all his pieces this
is obvious without further comments and
finally I think the Rook comes in with
Checkmate Rook AC gate check notice that
the B4 square is under control so the
king would have to go to D4 and E5 would
have been made
yeah definitely a
I don't know how to characterize this
game more straightforward than I was
expecting from our first battle against
a 2000 plus opponent but that's how
these things go
so
where did things go terribly wrong for
our opponent well first of all this
whole Knight F3 business is essentially
unnecessary right if you're already
playing this then go open Sicilian with
Knight F3 there's no downside to playing
the move Knight F3 it's not like white
is really avoiding anything through this
move order although I faced it quite a
bit in tournament play myself I think
the only quote-unquote trap that this
move order sets is this move E5 which is
what a lot of players would do without
knowledge of uh this line thinking oh
well that's a trap Knight takes C5 Queen
A5
Deja Vu wins the night unfortunately
after C3 as I was talking about during
the game this is a terrible version of a
Smith more black is not lost here after
D6 but hopefully you're able to see that
you've created you know these massive
light Square weaknesses in the center
after Bishop C4 White's development
Advantage becomes very alarming and if
black makes one more careless move after
an ig5 the game is already over because
there's just no way to defend F7
so if you've stumbled into this in this
position I believe that the best move is
actually to play Knight C6 and this
transposes into a variation of the
allopin which is sometimes reached via
the which is normally reached via the
two E5 move order this is by the way a
very legitimate line against the
elephant it's gotten pretty popular
recently and if white plays D4 here and
after the mass trade on D4 one of the
top theoretical moves is Bishop C4 and
bang we've transposed directly into that
line after Knight F6 this is a common
position
so instead you can reach it via the E5
C3 Knight C6 CD Ed and now either Bishop
C4 or Knight takes D4 we've transposed
into into that alopin line via this move
water if Knight G5 in this position I
don't think this works because black has
a check on B4
and the point of that check is actually
to get yourself to Castle so that you
protect the F7 Pawn this is a unique
kind of defensive resource that doesn't
exist in a lot of positions where you
face the the fried liver type attack
also of course black has D5 in this
position
but here after Ed you do get a very
fried Livery type situation
and black could get caught on the
crossfire very quickly
so
in any case uh we don't touch the movie
five we don't need that you can also
consider the move D5 but this is
unnecessarily theoretical just play the
move that you normally play in this case
Knight C6 and Bishop C4 I think is a
serious mistake I think this is a very
serious mistake because after Knight F6
I don't see a way for white to actually
keep material equality any longer of
course our opponent overlooked Knight
takes E5 this was the source of all of
white struggles but even if white
doesn't play E5 what does white play
right it's hard to defend this E4 Pawn
if white says okay let me go into the
open Sicilian no we're actually going to
take this Pawn
and it's worth noting that Bishop takes
F7 actually might be possible and might
even be the best move
with the idea well what is White's idea
who can tell me how white recovers the
piece here and there is a way there is a
way for white to recover the Knight but
it's not what you might think it is
there's also a trap here
so it's not this right a lot of you
might think it's this it's not this
because the Knight drops back you
actually have to go diagonally Queen H5
diagonal checks are the hardest checks
to block
and after King G8 the queen swings over
to D5 and picks up E4 and I think this
is a very instructive position if you're
watching on YouTube you pause and try to
evaluate this who do you think is better
and why so I'll let you kind of marinate
on that for a second how would you
evaluate this position if you had to
give an approximate computer assessment
who's better and why
so
if two people were arguing here there's
sort of two obvious factors and the
question is well which of them outweighs
the other from White's perspective black
has this very awkward King on G8 and
this awkward situation with the Rook on
h8 locked in the corner but that
actually pales in importance to Black's
assets and black has two major assets
the first is the bishop pair which is
going to become important later on the
second is black Central superiority
which we can really show by playing the
move D5 attacking the queen this forces
White's hand if white takes on C6 then
he allows us to further bolster our
already monster Center whereas if white
drops the queen back first of all this
is a very awkward move this walks into
Bishop C5 and the engine gives a funny
line Bishop takes Knight takes Bishop
takes and white can't defend the B-2
Pawn
so that's out of the question and if the
queen goes the other way to D3 this is
better but now this allows E5 and we
really unfurl our Center just look at
this Center construction which is
incredibly safe it can be safeguarded
further with Bishop to D6 bolstering the
E5 Pawn no question in my mind that
black is clearly better after Bishop D6
is the game over no you might say well
how is black gonna solve the problem of
the rook in the corner well you can
actually bring your king back out to F7
then kind of Castle by hand by moving
The Rook out and tucking the king back
on G8 but you don't really need to do
that immediately The Rook on h8 is
chilling we don't need the services of
The Rook just yet so one of the key
takeaways from the games that we're
playing at a higher level is that things
are no longer going to be one-sided you
have to learn how to look at the
position from multiple perspectives and
you have to understand that just because
your position has a flaw particularly a
visually arresting flaw that doesn't
mean that you're not better and that
doesn't mean your position's bad your
most of the time going to have good
things and bad things about your
position as the games get more complex
and you have to learn how to weigh those
factors and that's one of the hardest
things in chess to do but hopefully this
was a little illustration of how to do
that better
questions on this discussion
if black trades Queens yeah probably
black would be close to winning the
ancient evil was was a plus one in
Black's favor I mean it's the chest out
convention which is kind of weak but I I
agree with that assessment I would say
it's about plus one in Black's favorite
now if white does not take on F7 if
white just castles well then we could
grab the center with D5 and there's zero
compensation for the pawn black is
essentially winning
so yeah and if if white plays I mean I
guess Queenie 2 might be the Lesser evil
but now the D4 Pawn is fully intact and
we can strike at the center again with
D5 trade the engine gives castle and we
could bring our Bishop out to G4 then we
could play E6 to support the Knight and
again white is a very hard time
recovering the pawn on D4 that he has
deliberately not captured
um
so after E5 the situation is for further
exacerbated white loses the second Pawn
our opponent insisted on keeping the
material as balanced as possible this
probably is the best move again if white
takes then of course Queen A5 picks up
the Knight and keeps the second extra
Pawn
and notice that we take on E5 with check
so white again can't recapture D4
okay so instead Queen takes D4 hopefully
the logic behind Knight takes Bishop was
uh understandable to people this is also
very good I considered this approach but
I like this quite a bit less because
also the G file could end up working in
White's favor Believe It or Not uh
because it might make it difficult for
us to develop our Bishop along this
diagonal if we're tied down to the G7
Pawn
so I much prefer the bishop pair as a
long-term Advantage as opposed to a
superficial weakening of our opponent's
king side which we can't exploit anyway
because we don't have our pieces
developed
so Knight takes Bishop now we strike
with D5
uh an important note is that this check
seems annoying but we can just block it
with our Queen in order to keep B7
protected so that wouldn't have been
dangerous Queen B3 we continue our
development somebody was asking why
didn't we play G6 why did we abandon
this idea because I think G6 is a little
bit too slow I think we need to
prioritize rapid King side development I
also think that E6 kills two birds with
one stone in the sense that it supports
the D5 pawn and the D5 Pawn is the pride
of our position we don't want to leave
that pawn without sufficient Defenders
for instance your Bishop G7 Knight C3
castles well white could start applying
pressure on that pawn with Rook D1 and
E6 is a little bit awkward it creates a
lot of dark Square weaknesses and I've
talked about this many times in the
speed run in many Sicilian positions you
want to be careful about combining the
moves G6 and E6 because you're weakening
a whole lot of dark squares white could
try to support uh entrench the bishop on
E5 and it's just a little bit awkward
here so hopefully
that gives you a sense of why we play D6
flexibility is very important and the
other key takeaway from this position is
that
you know yes you're blocking the bishop
on C8 but you don't have to develop
every piece instantly urgently you can
put some of those tasks off to later on
in the middle game after you've
completed let's say the development of
your king side which is exactly what we
did we finished the development of our
King side and now we very calmly solve
the problem of our final undeveloped
piece with B6 this move kind of
exacerbates White's defeat if I was
playing white here I would try to keep
the center closed I would maybe go
Knight B to D2 and maybe try to get the
Knight around to the king side except
there's nothing to attack black has zero
Targets in our position that white can
attack white doesn't have anything to
latch onto so we would have just kept
improving our position
you know with Rook C8 and maybe sticking
the knight uh into the center on e4 that
would be another possibility so you know
black is
winning here from a technical standpoint
no question about it but white
definitely could have continued the game
longer
yeah see C4 just walks into our hands
because it opens up the position that
favors the side that has the bishop pair
in this case again note that this end
game might have been the best way for
white to prolong his Agony but black
just has everything that we could
possibly ask for here we would have
played Knight D5 these pawns are now
weak and the a file is nothing to be
concerned about because we could just
stick our Pawn on A5 and build a little
punch in and free up our Rook
uh so you know in any case Queen C2 we
stick the knight in the center
we bring the bishop out and queen C8 I
think is is a really instructive move
because we don't just play the most
obvious move in the position which would
have been Rook C8 which would have been
perfectly fine we use contact between
pieces to force the Queens off the board
white should have taken on C8 we would
have taken maybe even the a rook maybe
with a c rook and we would have reached
this end game which is again technically
winning for black no question about it
this bishop is a monster or up upon the
other Bishops coming out to F6 The Rook
is diving into C2 and white can't stop
everything at the same time also because
White's constantly dealing with problems
related to the a pawn again contact
between pieces
you can dig around in the send game if
you want to learn a little bit about
engine technique but hopefully you can
understand the blacks
essentially completely winning here
okay so Queen B3 Knight takes up four we
have nothing to discuss after that the
only alternative that was semi-viable
would have been Queen A4 and here we
would have had a choice between grabbing
the like complete Bishop pair two
Bishops versus two knights and then
maybe building a Queen Bishop battery
against G2 more probably I would have
taken twice on C3
and I don't see a downside to that
because Rook D7 fails the A1 Rook is
hanging and this is not really an
initiative we could just drop our Queen
on A3
and after the trade we are now up two
pawns this is not scary one Rook on the
seventh rank isn't going to make any
difference especially because the other
isn't able to access D7 and again at
this point the win is a matter of very
straightforward
Technique we go Rook fc8 we get the
other pair of Rooks off the board and we
win straightforwardly
um
so yeah a pretty dry game unfortunately
after the bishop was blundered there is
nothing left to talk about
uh but does anybody have any questions
about the course of the game
simple position to end
kinds of games that you're actually
going to end up winning I I think the
speedrun gives you a realistic portrayal
of what games that each level looks like
and not every game is going to be super
glamorous super rich and super full of
tactical ideas you need to know how to
beat players who are playing badly and
how to do it efficiently and the best
way to do it is to play Simple
straightforward positional chests so
thank you all
foreign
[Music]